We know many of the Muslims who when
they go for a job and if the boss says
you know the beard is a bit shabby I'll
give you a job if you remove the beard
and many of us next day will shave the
beard it's a shame on us
it's a shame on us the six a minority of
a minority in the world population it's
insignificant yet they want to identify
themselves as six
I'm not talking about all all the
Muslims I'm talking about few Muslims
who are afraid to wear the label it's a
shame
and a beloved prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he said it's
mentioned Muslim
volume number two in the book of salah
hadith number 1932 as well as 1933 and
1934 in three hadith the beloved prophet
said that when you go for the e in salah
for salah of and
the razanid and the bakar which as we
know here when you go for the salah of
this toen
take along with you the young women as
well as the menstruating women as well
as the para observing women even though
the menstruating women they do not offer
salah they only supplicate take them
along a prophet said when you go for the
ein salah Huh? Take along with you the
children, the young women, the para
observing women, even the menstruating
women even if they cannot pray. What was
the logic of the beloved prophet to
command the Muslim Ummah to go along
with the young women, para observing
women as well as the menstruating women
even if they cannot offer salah. What
was the logic?
The logic is
that as we know for the Eid salah
all the people gather
under one place especially in the
villages if two three villages are close
by they gather in a Eid ga a place where
they offer Eid salah together in the
city in Bombay it's a bit different you
know because it's a city it's a vast
city it's difficult we can't go outside
Bombay it's too far so we have the salah
in various mosques but yet we try and
see to it the congre congregation is big
but normally in the other places
villages etc you gather together in the
open ground ink
for example if there are three small
villages if they have a common idka so
the Muslims when he comes for the Eid
salah
he sees 30,000 Muslims in these three
small villages 30,000 Muslims the morale
of the Muslims is boosted he feels proud
30,000 Muslims all gathered together you
know you can make out that the Muslims
the morale is boosted
and if a non-Muslim
when he sees 30,000 Muslims in these
three small villages
he will think 10 times before creating
mischief with the Muslims if he has to
create any trouble for the Muslims he
will think a 100 times
and simultaneously the morale of the
Muslim is boosted
That's why beloved prophet said when you
go for salah gather in congregation
along with the children young women para
observing women as well as the
menstruating women even if they cannot
offer salah
for example if you're traveling in a bus
driving a BT bus
and suppose
there is a Muslim sister of ours who's
driving in a bus
And
if in that bus
along with the Muslim sister
sitting somewhere else there are about
five to 10 Muslims
sitting in the bus wearing the label
wearing a cap and sporting a beard.
These 10 people don't know each other.
Neither do they know that Muslim girl.
But if a non-Muslim
wants to create mischief
with the Muslim girl, if he wants to
create trouble for the Muslim girl, for
the Muslim, huh? The non-Muslim will
think 10 times. Oh, there are 10 people
in the bus. You know, Muslim wearing a
cap and sporting a beard. He will think
10 times before creating mischief. Even
if those 10 people are old people, they
can't even raise a finger. Even if they
can't hurt anyone yet, only seeing them,
he will think 10 times. Oh, 10 people
who are Muslims, if I create mischief,
these 10 people will pounce on me.
It does wonders. Wearing the label does
wonders. It does not only benefit you,
it even benefits your other Muslim
brothers and sisters.
Once
there was an elderly gentleman who was a
good Muslim alhamdulillah prayed five
times a day had gone for Hajj he was a
he always fast in the month of Ramadan
he gave the zakat he was a pious Muslim
but he did not have any label then wear
the cap did not sport a beard one day
when he goes on the streets to buy some
fruits from the hawker
And he asks the name of the hawker, that
young boy that said, "Beta son, what's
your name?" But he says, "Uncle,
my name is Ahmed."
So the elderly Muslim, he says, "Wait a
son, why didn't you wish me salam?"
So the young Ahmed says, "Uncle, I
thought you were a Hindu."
Imagine the young boy. He calls the
elderly pious gentleman a mushri.
The biggest abuse you can give to any
Muslim is to call him a mushri. There is
no bigger abuse for a Muslim than to
call him a mushri.
And the glorious Quran says in surah
nisa 4:48 as well as in surah nisa 4
vers 116 that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
never forgiveth the sin of associating
partners with Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
any other sin if Allah pleases he may
forgive but associating partners with
Allah shik he will never forgive for
committing shik is the most hinous sin
I am asking a question who is to blame
Who's to blame? Because he called that
elderly gentleman Amushri.
And the glorious Quran says in surah Ma
chapter number 5 verse number 72
that they said
the Christians that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him is Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala. Jesus Christ peace
be upon him the son of Mary is Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala the verse continues
but said Christ
of Israel
worship Allah
who's my lord and your lord
and anyone who associate partners with
Allah
Allah will make for him
and fire shall be his dwelling place and
he shall have no helpers in the
hereafter. The glorious Quran says that
anyone who associate partners with
Allah,
Allah will make jaham for him.
Anyone who does shik, he will go to
hell. If he dies as a mushri, he'll go
to hell. I am asking a question. Who is
to blame?
If a young Muslim boy calls the elderly
gentleman a mushri, who's to blame?
You can't blame that young boy? He's
innocent.
It is the elderly gentleman who's to
blame.
That why doesn't he wear the label? If
the label shows your intent, you should
wear it.
What is the label for the Muslim? For
the Muslim woman even they have a label.
The glorious Quran says in surah Nur
chapter number 24 verse number 31
that say to the believing woman that
they should lower their gaze and guard
their modesty and display not the beauty
except what appears ordinarily of and
draw their veil over the bosom and
display not the beauty except to the
husbands their fathers their sons and a
big list of maram the close relatives
who she can't marry is given.
And the criteria for hijab is mentioned
in the Quran and the say had there
basically six criteria.
The first is the extent which differs
between the man and the woman. For the
man is from the navl to the knee. For
the woman the complete body should be
covered except the face and the hands up
to the wrist. Some scholars say even the
feet below the ankle can be seen. There
are some scholars who say that even the
face and the hands should be covered.
This is extinct. The remaining five
criterias is the same for the man and
the woman. The second is that the
clothes they wear
it should not be so tight that it
reveals the figure.
We have many of our Muslim brothers who
wear jeans that are so stretch jeans you
know skintight stretch jeans
wearing skin tight stretch jeans aa of
the man is from the navl to the knee he
cannot wear any clothes which reveals
the figure of that part you know skin
tight where you can see the curves it's
not allowed
the third the clothes they wear it
should not be transparent so So that you
can see through the Muslim women may be
covering the body. They may be wearing
loose clothes but it may be transparent
you know made of jo or something like
that that's not allowed. Fourth is it
should not be so glamorous that it
attracts the opposite sex. Fifth is it
should not resemble that of the
unbeliever. Any label which is a
specific sign of an unbeliever a Muslim
cannot wear. For example, a Muslim
cannot wear a cross. It's a specific
sign of Christianity.
He cannot wear Om which is a sign of
Hinduism. He cannot wear a vermillon or
a tikka which is a sign of Hindu.
He cannot wear any specific signs which
is a sign of an unbeliever.
And the sixth criteria is you cannot
wear clothes that which resemble the
opposite sex.
If you go to the western countries, you
have many boys and gents. They wear a
earring only one earring.
It has certain significance. If you wear
one earring, it has certain
significance.
And the Indians whatever America does
after a few years when we follow and you
find even in Bombay nowadays men wearing
one earring.
According to Islamic Sharia, you cannot
wear clothes that which resembles that
of the opposite sex. And the reason for
hijab for the woman is given in surah
haz 33:59
where it says that, "Oh prophet, tell
your wives and the believing woman that
when they go abroad, they should put on
the cloak so that they shall be
recognized and it will prevent them from
being molested." The Quran says that
hijab has been prescribed for the women
so that they shall be recognized and it
will prevent them from being molested.
For example,
if
two sisters who are twins
and if both of them are very beautiful,
they're equally beautiful. If they're
walking down the streets of Bombay and
if one of the twin sister he's wearing
the Islamic hijab, the complete body
covered except the face and the handle
of the wrist
and the other twin sister she's wearing
the western clothes the skirt or the
mini and if they're walking down the
streets and if round the corner there is
a hulligan there is a ruffian who's
waiting for a catch who's waiting to
tease a girl I am asking a question
which girl will he tease Will he tease
the girl wearing the Islamic hijab or
will he tease the girl wearing the skirt
or the mini? Which girl will he tease?
But naturally, he will tease the girl
wearing the skirt or the mini. The Quran
rightly says that hijab has been
prescribed for the woman so that it
shall prevent them from being molested.
There are some of our Muslim sisters who
may give the excuse
that when we wear the hijab, when we
wear the scarf or when we wear the coat
or the hijab, the people just stare at
us.
Therefore, it is unnecessary attracting
attention.
I tell them, I do agree with you. There
may be cases in which because you're
unique, no one around you is wearing the
hijab. And if you wear the hijab, people
may look at you because you're odd. The
odd men out or rather the odd woman out.
It may it may happen. But I tell them
that when the people look at you when
you wear the hijab, they don't look at
you with lust. They look at you with
respect. There's a difference. To the
other lady who's wearing the skirt or
the mini, the men look at with lust.
to you. If they look at you, they look
at you with respect. They may look at
you because
you may look unique, but when they look
at you, they look at you with respect.
And you can ask this question to the
ladies who do hijab and even my sister,
alhamdulillah, she confirms that because
we wear the hijab, alhamdulillah, the
people around us respect us. When we go
in the bus, they offer us a seat.
Alhamdulillah.
It elevates the position of the woman.
And many women think that if you have to
wear a hijab, you have to wear a black
burka. It is compulsory.
Nowhere does the Islamic Sharia say that
you should wear only a black burka.
As long as it doesn't attract the
opposite sex, you can wear any color.
You can wear brown, you can wear blue,
you can wear white, you can wear ivory,
you can wear any color. Maybe people
prefer black, you know, because if you
wear a black burka, you may have to wash
it once in a week or once in a
fortnight. If you wear a white burka,
you may have to wash it every day or
maybe every alternate day. So the choice
is yours. You can either wear a black
burka and wash it once a week or wear a
white burka or light color burka and
wash it every couple of days. The option
is yours. Nowhere does Islamic Sharia
say that you should wear black. If you
want, you can wear black. You can wear
any color as long as you follow the six
criterias of the Islamic Sharia.
We have many Muslims especially living
in India who have various types of
surnames and names and there are various
surnames which match with the surnames
of the non-Muslims
and especially the Muslims of the Koken
region the cookies and even I'm a cook
so that no Cockney feels offended
and if you analyze the surname of
certain Muslims depending on the region
they're coming from Their surname
resembles that of the non-Muslims, of
the Hindus. You have a Takur, a Muslim
Takur and a Hindu Takur. You have the
Patel, the Muslim Patel and a Hindu
Patel. You have the Nike Nike. My
surname is Nike. You have the Muslim
Knight and the Hindu KN.
You have Pawkar, a Muslim Pavaskkar and
a Hindu Pawkar. You have Muslims coming
from the Gujarat side who have surnames
like Sha. You have a Muslim Sha, you
have a Hindu sha surname like Desai. You
have a Muslim desai and a Hindu desai.
We cannot identify from the surname
whether the person is a Muslim or a
non-Muslim.
If you read the tradition of beloved
prophet, the prophet never ever changed
the family name. He never advised the
people to change the family name. You
know why? The family name shows the
roots and identification of the roots is
very important in Islam. Therefore the
prophet never ever recommended any
Muslim to change his family name
whatever his name was because if you
know ah nik ki coming from koken region
you come to know the roots ah takur if
you're a Muslim coming from the koken
region ah sha coming from the gujad side
you come to know the lineage the area
where you come from but many a times
along with a surname which may get mixed
up with a non-Muslim you even have names
names which can get mixed up with the
non-Muslims.
You have Muslim huh Muslim women who
have the name Kishwar. You have a Muslim
Kishwar and a non-Muslim Kishwar.
You have names such as
Sheila. There are some Muslim women who
have the name Sheila. Even the Hindu as
Sheila. You have Danish, Muslim Danish
and a Pari Danish.
There are certain names which are common
and some of the Muslims when they have a
non-Muslim type of surname like Tapur
Patel or Nik
they take advantage of situation
and
they try and manipulate if they're
meeting a Muslim certain names of
Muslims are identical you can easily
identify as a Muslim like Abdullah
Sultan Muhammad Zakir No two doubts that
Abdullah Zakir, Muhammad, Sultan, they
are Muslims. No two doubts.
So if you have a label which clearly
identifies and a name specific, there's
no two doubts that you are a Muslim. But
certain Muslims there advantage. If they
have a surname which matches with a
non-Muslim, if they meet a Muslim, they
say the full name
like Muhammad Nik full name, that's the
name of my brother.
And if they meet a non-Muslim they say
am n it can be manag
it can be manoj. My brother doesn't do
that. But I'm telling the example so
that no one feels hurt. No one says that
I'm particularly pinpointing because
it's very common. They write Mik only
Mik or
Ma Nike MD Nike whatever it is. You
can't identify whether a Muslim or
non-Muslim when they meet Muslims they
say the full name.
So using such things intentionally
trying to manipulate that if a Muslim
comes maybe I get good customers I want
to identify I'm a Muslim if a non-Muslim
comes I try and deceive him it is
nothing but deception which Islam is
completely against
if your name happens to resemble a
non-Muslim if your surname no problem
keep it but don't use the strategy of
trying to win over people by deceiving
them Islam doesn't permit that be proud
of your name. Alhamdulillah and identify
yourself to be as Muslims. You know when
you go to school you are particular
uniform that if you're going to St.
Peter school the school which I went to
you have gray trousers and white shirt
you can immediately identify he is a St.
Peteride a student of St. Peter school
if he's going to St. Mary school he has
white trousers and white shirt identify
that he is a student of St. Mary school
and they have particular different color
ties etc. It's easy to identify. They
wear a uniform known as the school
uniform.
It identifies a person
in the organization which I come from
Islamic Research Foundation. Even we
have a label in a foundation. You know
some people wear their blazers, blue
blazers or a particular trousers, navy
blue trousers and light blue shirt. In
the Islamic Foundation, our label is cap
and a beard. Any person wants to join
IRF the first criteria in the interview
we tell him is that if you join this
it's compulsory you should wear a cap
and sport a beard no two option whether
the beard suits you or not it's
compulsory if you keep it for the love
of Allah and his rasool inshallah you'll
get sab you should do it for that but
irrespective whether you like it or not
if you want to join IRF Islamic research
foundation as an employee it's
compulsory wearing a cap and sporting a
beard. Alhamdulillah, that's our label.
We prefer the label of Islam for the
people working in IRS. It's compulsory.
You know the doctors. When a person
becomes a doctor from the name Mr. So
and So, it changes to doctor so and so.
You know why? Because being a doctor,
alhamdulillah, it's a noble profession.
It elevates you. Other people are good
people, but I'm a doctor. I'm of a noble
profession from mister it changes to
doctor and if a doctor has a car he puts
a cross on his car on his vehicle to
identify the doctor that if a person if
he's going on the streets and if he
requires any help if a person has an
accident they can easily stop a doctor's
car ah this person is of a medical
profession
if the label shows your intent you wear
it similarly we Muslims alhamdulillah
If the label shows your intent, you
should wear it. You should be proud to
identify yourself as Muslims. So that if
any person requires any spiritual help,
any help where iman is concerned, where
faith is concerned, he can approach a
person wearing a cap and putting a
beard. It's easy. It identifies you.
There are various benefits of wearing
the label. various benefits besides you
getting Sabah because you're following
Allah and his you'll get Sabah for that
there are various benefits if suppose
you go to an area which is new to you
and if the time for salah is there and
you want to go to the mosque
who will you ask where is the mosque you
look for a person wearing a cap and a
beard okay he's a Muslim he will be able
to guide me even if it's a small mosque
he may know that okay it's there in a
small gully or if it's a big mosque he
there it's there
and if a person travels a lot you know
I'm a person who travel a lot and when
we go to the western country we have a
big problem the Muslim for halal food
for having zabya food now where are we
going to ask a person where do we get
halal food if you ask a non-Muslim where
halal food he will not understand what
is halal food there's a problem so we
look at a person ah one person amongst
hundreds of them wearing a cap and a
beard brother salamkum salam wish them
the man and ask them where can a halal
food it's difficult it's very far why
don't you come to a house I will give
you alhamdulillah you don't have to pay
also for that not that you have to wear
the label so that you save your money
for the food but it does wonders it has
happened several times with me when you
go to an area where there's no halal
food and you ask the Muslim brother
offers why don't you come to my house
all he says okay there's a restaurant
which is just like a left on our right
and second lane again in the left and
you find a restaurant there.
Alhamdulillah, it does wonders
and
it opens the opportunity for doing dawa.
If you wear the label, it allows you to
do a compulsory duty of the Muslim that
is propagate the message of Islam. It
does wonders and there are various types
of labels. For example, if you go to the
house of a Muslim, you know, if the
Muslim wants to identify himself as a
Muslim, he may have certain posters or
certain big lettering, ayats, Arabic
writing, maybe like
all is due to the bounty of the beloved
Lord.
It may say, "Oh my Lord, increase me
knowledge." You can easily identify that
this house belongs to a Muslim. Maybe
mention Allah Abbar easy. And now
technology is advancing and new labels
are coming up with the help of
technology. You have a clock giving out
the aan the aan clock. When you ring the
bell it says assalamu alaykum new labels
are being invented. Alhamdulillah it may
help you.
And
if you go
to an office
in the office you may have certain
inscription or certain posters that
indicate that this office belongs to a
Muslim.
If you enter the alter of Islam is the
foundation the first ayat in front
the only religion the only dean
acceptable in the sight of Allah is
Islam directly no problem indicates that
this promises belongs to a Muslim. When
you drive in a vehicle in a car you may
have certain stickers mentioning
in the name of Allah most gracious most
merciful. And nowadays you know I have a
habit when I go out and travel abroad
for my friends I get certain tokens like
keychains Islamic key chains and once
when I've gone to Jada a new device is
fitted it's a device which you put in
the car the moment you switch on the car
the moment you give the ignition it
starts alhamdulillah
it starts the dua when when you start
the journey which a prophet recommended
that praise be to Allah and seek Allah's
guidance that he may have control over
the vehicle etc. And if the passenger
sitting next to you, if he doesn't know
the dua, he memorizes it. Alhamdulillah,
it does wonders. There are various
labels available.
And when I came the first time to
Milagar, it was after the riots about in
the year 1993 about more than 5 years
back. The first time when I came to
Milagar and when I entered and when I
read the name of the buildings al-
Makkah al- Madina Malifa Arafad Mina
believe me touched my heart
alhamdulillah
I was so impressed that this full colony
I had known that it's one of the biggest
colony of Muslims but when I entered
Makkah Medina Malifa Mina alhamdulillah
it impressed me a lot.
every building the moment you read the
name anyone can realize that this is a
Muslim building
and when the people staying in Milagar
when they go out and say that if person
ask you where do you stay and if you say
I stay in Milagar it's taken for granted
you are a Muslim
even where you're staying identifies
what religion you belong to
alhamdulillah
but unfortunately
when I came next time I realized that
the buildings had the labels but
everyone living in the building didn't
have the label.
So when they go out
and when they look at them people may
not realize whether it's a Muslim or not
I'm not saying all the people of Milagar
many I have seen alhamdulillah who are
the label. So inshallah when I come next
time to milagar inshallah
I would be happy that besides the
buildings having the Islamic name even
the label is there on each and every
individual.
Inshallah I hope that will be the case
that next time when I come to Milat
Nagar all of them inshallah besides
having the label on the building in the
place where they're staying they should
even have the label on themselves that
when they travel out people recognize
that he's a Muslim she's a Muslim she's
a Muslim woman
a Muslim should never ever be afraid to
identify himself as a Muslim
The only reason that a Muslim may not
like to identify himself as a Muslim is
if he doesn't agree that Islam is the
best way of life. He may be a namesake
Muslim may be born in a Muslim family
given a Muslim name otherwise a Muslim
will never feel afraid to wear his
label. He may feel afraid if he doesn't
know the answers
because if you wear the label you're
proclaiming that I am a person following
the religion of hak the religion of
truth
and whenever there's a competition
between truth and falsehood truth always
prevails truth always wins people
sometime afraid that if people come to
my Muslim I may lose my customers I have
non-Muslim customers I may lose them
he's afraid
But if he knows Islam,
if he identify himself as a Muslim, that
he's a person following truth, he will
inshallah benefit even in his business.
Because the Quran clearly states and I
would like to end my talk with the
quotation of the Quran from surah Isra
chapter number 17 verse number 81 which
says
when truth is heard against falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to perish.
Alhamdulillah.
[Applause]
We now move on to the second part of the
program, the question and answer
session.
We have certain suggested guidelines
for conducting this question and answer
session to analyze the topic. If the
label shows your intent, wear it
adequately for all those who are present
here today. In the limited time
available, we would like to follow these
guidelines during this session.
Questions posed should be on the topic.
If the label shows your intent, wear it.
Questions not relevant to the topic,
including any general questions on
religion will not be entertained. Kindly
state your question briefly and to the
point. Only one question may be asked at
a time. For your second question, move
down behind the line, behind the queue
you'll be standing for. We have two mics
here in the gen section and one mic in
the ladies section.
brothers who are uh maybe shy of asking
questions or coming forward. We we'd
prefer if you can come forward and ask
your questions on the mic. But in case
uh you you would like you have the
alternative to ask your questions or
write down your questions on the slip
and pass it down to the volunteers who
are waiting in the aisles to give you
the slip. May we have a first question
please?
My name is Dr. Abuakar Tahiralam.
My question is that I was told during
the 1993 riots those people were wearing
the labels were identified and hunted
down and killed the in Bombay. In such
situation I think we should avoid we
wearing the label in the face of danger
to our life. Thank you.
The brother asked a question that during
the riots which took place in Mumbai
1992 and 1993
many people were afraid of their lives
and many people removed the label. So is
it right to remove the label during such
things?
Every rule has an exception and the
Quran clearly mentions that if under
compulsion if under compulsion
unwillingly you can even do shik for
example if someone puts a gun on your
temple on your head and asks you are you
a Muslim or a mushik deep within your
hearts you know that I'm a Muslim but to
save your life under compulsion as a
last resort the Quran gives you an
option that you can tell a lie in this
situation If life and death is the
question only of the situation similarly
during rights you are living in a
non-Muslim area and suppose if you step
out and your life will be in danger in
such situation if you remove your label
inshallah Allah will forgive you for
example if in a right round the corner a
non-Muslim puts a gun on your temper
Muslim or non-Muslim you have option of
saying you're a Muslim and become sh or
say I'm a non-Muslim and save both is
allowed. If around the corner no one is
watching me, what is the use?
I have option of either say I'm Muslim
become shah or say I'm a non-Muslim,
Quran gives permission. So here if a
person says I'm a non-Muslim and saves
his life so that he can spread Islam
afterwards. Alhamdulillah.
Similarly, if someone asks me on a stage
where there are hundreds and thousands
of people watching me, are you Muslim or
non-Muslim? Here also I have the option
both of either say I'm Muslim or
non-Muslim. But here the hikmah may say
that if I give shahada there are
hundreds and thousands of people
watching me it may boost up the morale I
may prefer saying I'm a Muslim and
become shah alhamdulillah. So Quran
gives both the permission and the
compulsion. Like the Quran says in surah
bakar chapter number 2 verse number 173
surah ma chapter number 5 verse number
three in surah chapter 6 verse 145 and
in surah nah chapter number 16 verse 115
that if unwillingly if you disobey Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala Allah is raman that
after saying that pork is forbidden for
you if unwillingly if you're dying of
hunger if pork is the only thing you can
find if you have gone in a boat and you
have no food and someone offers you pork
for your survival you can eat that much
which is sufficient for you to survive
not eat your tummy full but the moment
you come on the shore again it becomes
prohibited so to save your life Islam
gives permission under compulsion
unwillingly if you say Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala Allah is raman here you have
an option that if you feel your life is
a ninja or you cannot bear the mental
torture no problem but alhamdulillah I
do know that there are few we will
remove the label and many of them the
moment that mosy became cordial they
wore the label again but I know of
hundreds of Muslims who did not wear the
label before the riots but after
observing the riots the morale was
boosted and they started wearing the
label. I personally know of hundreds of
Muslims alhamdulillah who after the
riots wore the labor seeing that okay
this was the situation we were in a
problem we should identify ourselves as
Muslims the moment the mental shock of
the riots was over alhamdulillah many
Muslims were label after the riots hope
that answers the question we have the
next question my name is Azam na I have
the very common question which we have
in our mind that is it permissible for a
Muslim to greet assalamu alaykum to a
non-Muslim and in case suppose if he
greet us with assalamu alaykum can we
say him walaykumalam kindly clarify the
brother asked a common question that can
a Muslim greet a non-Muslim with
assalamu alaykum or if a non-Muslim
greets assalamu alaykum can you wish
back welcome assalam
and I'm aware that there are many
scholars
who do say that when a Muslim wishes
youalamu alaykum you have to say alaykum
and this answer is based in several had
which are given in say Muslim and if you
read say Muslim volume number three in
the book of salam
chapter number 94
hadith number 5380 to 5390 there are 11
had mentioned in say Muslim regarding
this topic but if you analyze the hadith
The first few hadith say that when the
Jews wished
aums
in Arabic means may death be on you.
When the Jews wish you akum, may death
be on you, the prophet said wish them
backum. May it be on you too. So the
reference to context is that when the
non-Muslims knowingly wish evil for
youamlaykum
sounding similar to assalamu alaykum
when they wish may death be on you you
have to wish back saying alaykum on you
too
but many of the scholars say that when
even the non-muslims wish asalamu
alaykum you have to wish back alaykum
which if you go into details you can get
the reply from from the Quran and the
Sai had let's see what does the Quran
say regarding
greeting back and I said in my talk in
surah chapter 4:86
which says
that when anyone greets you courteously
wish back more courteously or a greeting
which is of equal courtesy because Allah
is careful in keeping of the accounts
where greeting back is concerned we can
greet them back. So regarding the
question if someone wishes you asalamu
alaykum what should you reply based on
this Quranic verse you can wish back
more courteously or at least the same
that's what the Quran says regarding can
you wish them first there are hadith of
beloved prophet in the same Muslim it
says that when you meet a you are a
Christian don't wish them etc and there
are various difference opinion in the
various groups of scholars but when you
go to the Quran Quran and the say hadith
is the best example to be followed. The
Quran says in surah Mariam chapter
number 19 verse number 47 that when
Ibrahim Alisam Abraham peace be upon him
when his father who was a mushri removes
him from his house he says assalamu
alaykum I will pray to Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala to forgive you.
Quran says that Ibraimam told his father
assalamu alaykum and I will pray to my
almighty god to forgive you further if
you read in surah taha chapter number
20:47 it says that mus alisam andam mo
and peace be upon them they were
commanded by Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
that when they delivered the message to
Pharaoh and his people to wish them by
saying peace be on them those who
receive guidance And this was one of the
way the prophet when he dictated letters
he said to the non-Muslim kings that
peace be on you those who receive
guidance.
Further if you read in surah furan
chapter 25 verse 63 it says that when
those approach you are ignorant tell
them
tell them peace. So when the ignorant
come to you
who give vain talks say
wish them peace.
Further in surah chapter 28 verse 55 it
says that when you are in the company of
those people who give vain talks and who
speak against Islam tell them to us is
our deeds to you is your deeds.
Peace be on you. Wish them salam. mean
those who speak against Islam, the Quran
says wish them salam. So there's no
problem at all in wishing a non-Muslim
salam. And if you read the tapas of the
Quranic verses, if you read the tapas of
Kurubi, regarding surah
Mariam chapter 19:47, it says that
regarding the explanation of this verse,
when Ibraimam tells his father that
peace be on you, I will ask Allah
forgive you. Most of the scholars, the
Jamur scholars, Ola, they say that here
the peace was only a form of greeting
like saying farewell. It wasn't a form
of asking protection. So they say that
this was a form of greeting. While in
his
he says that according
to
he said that here it actually means
peace. And further if you read the
statement of Nakash he said that it is
allowed for the Muslims to wish salam to
the non-Muslim
though the majority of the scholars say
that here the greeting was only a form
of a greeting. It was not asking for
protection.
And further if you read the statement
which kubi says that I agree more with
the statement of
who said and for his explanation he
quotes surah mumahena chapter number 60
verse number 8 and say Allah forbids not
you
from being just to those people who
fight you not against the religion nor
drive you out of your house for Allah
loves those who are just. That means you
have to be just to the people who fight
you not against your religion or drive
you not out of your house. And he
further says that the Quran says in
surah mahina chapter number 60 verse
number four that verily in the lifestyle
of Ibrahimam you find a very good
example. What Ibrahim Alisallam did
alhamdulillah you find a very good
example. So when he can wish peace to
his father why can't you? So based on
the scholars if you see the tapas
various even of tabri and kasir when he
gives the translation and the commentary
of surah nisa chapter 4 vers86 he says
that this verse which says that when
anyone wishes you courteously wish back
more courteously does not refer to the
muslim it can refer to any creature of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
So if you analyze there are a few group
of scholars who say that it is
preferable that you do not wish them
only say allaykum but there are other
group of scholars who say that you can
wish them you can initiate the greeting
as well as wish them back more
courteously. I agree more with those
group of scholars who say that you can
greet non-Muslims because if you read
the sayings of Masoud may Allah be
pleased with him when he was asked can
you greet salam to a non-Muslim he said
yes and he did that to his companions
and he said we Muslims have come here to
spread peace if you read the sayings of
Abu Salam may Allah be pleased with him
he said that he used to greet the
non-Muslims other Christian Jews etc
with peace
So there are scholars majority who do
say that you can wish while many
scholars who say that it's preferable to
sayum I agree more with those who say
that you can wish salam to a non-Muslim
as well as wish them back welcome hope
that answers the question we have the
question from the ladies section
helloalamikum
uh it is generally felt that the tie is
the symbol of the cross then why do you
wear the label of the question
that's a very good question posed by the
sister and I'm happy that such question
has come so that you know many
misconceptions are clarified she has a
question that tai is a symbol of a cross
symbol of Christian then why as I being
a Muslim wear the tie and I do know that
many Muslims consider the tie to be a
symbol of a cross but I'm a student of
comparative religion nowhere in any
Christian scripture is it mentioned that
tie is a sign of a cross and if it is
the hadith clearly says that you cannot
wear that which resembles that of an
unbeliever if it's a specific symbol of
a non-Muslim you cannot wear that label
it is haram nowhere will you find a
single statement in any verse of the
bible where it says that tie is a sign
of a cross I'm aware that many Muslims
they are against the western culture and
I don't blame them what I say if you
find something against if you observe
something which the westerners are doing
wrong you have to object to it but what
things they do good there's no harm in
agreeing with it what things are neutral
there's no harm not that you have to
object to that also many Muslims are so
much against the western culture that
they object on each and everything
is not at all the symbol of Christianity
and this question is posed to me in
various parts of the world and I
challenge and I tell the audience that
if any Muslim can prove to me any time
with authentic proof that tie is a sign
of a cross of a Christian I will be the
first person to remove it and I will
tell all the people not to wear it tie
is not a sign of Christianity at all
it's not a sign of a cross at all it's a
cultural dress and researches have been
done by scholars not from hearsay from
scholars. How did it originate? Some
scholars say in the cold countries,
people wore a tie to
tie their garments which were heavy. You
know, in the cold countries, you know,
woolen clothes, etc. It's a cultural
dress. It's not a dress of the
Christian. You go throughout the world,
the Christian wear, he wears a tie.
Alhamdulillah, I know about it. The
Muslim wears it, the Hindu wears it. It
is not specifically a sign of
Christianity. It's a cultural test. And
a Muslim is allowed to adopt any culture
as long as it doesn't go against the
Islamic Sharia. If that culture goes
against the Islamic Sharia like wearing
shorts, it's the culture of the
westerners. We Muslim can't adopt it
because for a man the hijab the a is
from the navl to the knee. He can't wear
shorts. It's not allowed traveling in a
car. The car was invented by the
Christian the westerners. Can I say the
Christian invented therefore I can't sit
in a car?
I don't have an airplane. Can I say
that? No. Whatever is against the
Sharia, you should not do. Thai is not a
sign of Christianity at all. This tie
people say it looks like a cross.
You open and you stretch the circle, it
becomes a cross. I tell the ka that you
wear. You put like that, it resembles
more like a cross.
So you can't invent your own thinking.
Oh, ka looks like a cross therefore stop
wearing ka. Can I tell that? Can I ever
tell that? See the prophet said anything
which is a symbol of a particular
religion don't wear those symbol. Tie is
not a symbol of Christianity. It's a
cultural test. It's not a f you should
wear a tie. I'm not saying that
you don't alhamdulillah I'm with you.
But when I go to the western country it
helps deleting certain barriers. And if
Islam doesn't object to that I don't
mind using it. If Islam objects to that,
I should not use anything which Islam
prohibits even if it benefits me. But
since this thing, alhamdulillah, is
allowed in Islam, there's no problem at
all if a person wears a tie. Hope that
answers the question, sister.
Can I have the next question from the
brother on the right side?
Asalamu alaikum, brother.
Uh I have a question. There are certain
Muslims who argue that they do not wear
a cap and a beard because they may
sometimes indulge in unislamic
activities like bribing, cheating,
telling lies etc. which will spoil the
name of Islam if they are identified as
Muslims. Are they correct?
The pose a question that there are
certain Muslims who say and argue that
we don't wear the label, the cap and the
beard because there are times that we
may indulge in wrong activities,
unislamic activities like bribing,
cheating, telling lies. So we don't want
to spoil the name of Islam. They are
concerned alhamdulillah they're
concerned about Islam. So therefore they
say we don't want to wear the label.
There are two types of people. One is a
pessimist and one is an optimist. The
pessimist is a person who always thinks
at the negative angle and we are such
people who we are quoting. We don't want
to wear the label because sometime on a
blue moon women do wrong activities like
bribing, cheating, telling lies. So we
don't want to spoil the name of Islam.
So I tell them that why don't you be an
optimist
that if you know that sometimes you do
bad things and once you start wearing
the label the cap and the beard and
suppose it happens that the opportunity
arises that you have to bribe you start
thinking oh now I'm wearing the label
how can I bribe and you will not bribe
alhamdulillah
if the opportunity comes where you can
cheat and you realize oh I'm wearing a
label how can I spoil the name of Islam
you will not
If you have to tell a lie to support
what you're saying and you realize oh
I'm wearing a label cap and the beard
you will not lie
irrespective whether it benefits you in
this world or not it will inshallah
inshallah it will benefit you and I
ended my talk by quoting the verse of
the Quran from surah is 17:81 that if
you are a Muslim
Muslim means a person who submits will
to Allah subhana wa tala he's proud to
be a Muslim He's proud to submit his to
Allah subhana wa tala proud to follow
religion of h if he's truly a Muslim he
should also follow the
and if he's on the Quran says in surah
17:81
when truth is falsehood falsehood
perishes for falsehood is by its nature
bound to perish so what I tell such
people that if you feel that once in a
while if you do wrong activities And if
you wear the label, it will spoil the
lame of a label. Instead of being a
pessimist, you become an optimist.
You wear a label and inshallah it will
make you a better Muslim. And if you're
so much concerned about the Muslim Umah
and the name of Islam, it will besides
helping the Muslim it will even help
you. It will help you and see to it that
you remain on Sarat Musakim. Hope that
answers the question.
The next question from brother on the
left, please.
Asalamu alaykum. My name is Farhan Khan
and I'm electronic engineer and by
profession I'm a businessman. In my
company where I'm working is mostly
Hindus and Jens and I have found that
people looking down upon on the on the
Muslims those who are wearing headgears
and even uh beard. So I would like to
know by I have studied Islam and
comparative religion to spread Islam if
we can keep ourselves away from at least
hair and beard we I found it is more
easy to make them explain
asked a question that he is a student of
comparative religion. Alhamdulillah may
Allah reward you. He says that if you
keep away from these labels like
headgear and beard it helps you to
spread Islam more. According to you,
everyone has the right to the opinion.
Brother, fortunately, when I happen to
be in this field, I'm not aware how much
dava you do, but alhamdulillah, I travel
throughout the world. This headgear
doesn't come in my way at all. Give me
one example. If you're a di that the
headgear comes in between your way, if
you are not a dai, if you're
materialistic, ah, if I'm a Muslim, if a
non-Muslim comes to know I'm a Muslim,
he will not come to my shop. If you are
a materialistic person temporarily you
may think it's a loss but you say you're
a student of comparative religion you
live with giants etc brother I am a d
I'm a full-time D alhamdulillah give me
one example in your experience in which
the head wave will come in your way
alhamdulillah it helps me it helps me
break the barriers yes brother you want
to give an example most welcome the
thing is that there may be situation in
which you may not know how to handle it
so Quran says in surah Nah 16:43 that if
you do not possess the knowledge ask of
those who possess the knowledge go to an
expert and he will show you how to solve
the problem don't take a decision which
is wrong yes brother what's the problem
I solve it see actually you are you are
a full-time D we are not a full-time D
we are doing a business along with that
I would like to do this work when I'm
sitting in my office I talk to my
employed people also I talk to them I
alhamdulillah at least one or two I
could make them even convinced but the
thing is that what I have around even
Gujarati and even those people when they
see you see even my colleague one
colleague is having a beard they don't
approach him and when they don't bring
him closer but when I go to them and I
talk to them I find that people are
listening to me so that's what I found
it is more easier for me to spread it
the brother has given an example that he
has his colleagues and he's not a
full-time D like me now he's changed
first he said a comparative religion now
he say he's not a full-time D no one is
stopping you from being a full-time D
it's the best profession better than a
medical doctor also I was a medical
Doctor I left my profession for a better
profession. Quran says in surah 41 verse
number 33 it says woman
who is better in speech than one who
invites the people to the way of thy
lord works righteousness and says I'm
the first to bow my will to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala. The best profession
is a profession of die. Regarding a
question that you have got colleagues
and he's not a full-time D. So the
colleagues they say that these people
they don't come close to the people who
have a beard and wear a cap. Brother
before I became a full-time NY I was a
student in a medical college and
majority of my colleagues were
non-Muslims. Katar very strong against a
Muslim. Alhamdulillah.